hey leute und herzlich willkommen mal
wieder zu einer neuen unseres mensch und
ich werde ihn vorschlagen mensch das ist
doch traurig so ja so ziemlich hektische
begrüßung ich war gerade ob ich unter
stand android bei sekunden runter hektar
jedenfalls habe ich mir gedacht dass ich
mal wieder eine runde smash aufnehmen
jetzt einfach nur zu ganz spontan neue
produkt okay so ich muss auf jeden fall
mal irgendwelche alte muss erst mal
finden man hier müsst ihr ding doch
einfach eigentlich immer weit herum oder
zuerst mit einer hammer bombe
nein da bin ich ja da ist er okay denn
ungespielt kinder kann ich kann gar
nichts
ja wo ist er hin
august in kraft nein nein nein habe ich
gespürt
gut jetzt habe ich nur noch an alle die
es nicht wissen nach unten die herzen
sind meinem leben als ich hab es noch
zwei leben
die haben alle schon schwerte das
natürlich relativ ungünstig so ich muss
ja auf jeden fall auch erstmal in welche
items finden hier liegt noch mangel die
kirche ist mein leben da muss erst mal
mit anderen wegschmelzen
ja okay das einer weg das gut
man muss irgendwie da oben drauf kann
also es geht darum man hat hier super
sprünge man kann auch so nimmt so eine
bombe machen die kirche so also mit
schiff dann einfach da steht in der
beschreibung ich hab das alles schon mal
gemacht von daher als welchen der
mannschaft das letzte mal ganz cool
wo ist der muss ja der ist unsichtbar
flippern so und man muss halt ganz lange
überleben ist die andere halt kein leben
mehr haben und da sind alle die noch
leben und ich habe irgendwie garten
allerdings bekommt weil ich meinen teil
noch nicht geöffnet habe ja ich mache
mal mein kreft in letzter zeit relativ
viel neues so ich bin oben drauf dass
das schon mal ganz cool
warum sie nach oben denn so fackeln den
baum komme ich nicht hoch doch komme ich
nein könig ich vielleicht mal so ich
mache es auch mal ein bommel ich jetzt
erstmal hier ganz schnell weg ich habe
keinen bock das medienleute hier hat
alles versauen vor allem jemand der
unsichtbar ist
der schnee war glaube ich noch back nine
okay obwohl es seit den usa denn wieso
ist denn dann unsichtbar
das ist jetzt echt komisch wusste er
halo ist entschieden dass ich mal jetzt
einfach hier zu einem bummel
aber ich habe ja ich habe keinen plan wo
der ist wie solchen das dann schaffen
warte vielleicht wenn ich hier unter
fallada um wahl zur warte vielleicht
sich jetzt ihr habt da oben sind wieder
da oben sind welche geht erst mal weg
ganz weg des led alter wenn also lag es
so voll dumm so warte ok jetzt ist er
zurück zum lobby dann packt noch etwas
hinten dran sonst das relativ kurz damit
könnt ihr in die kommentare schreiben
was ihr so für pvp sachen sehen wollt ob
ihr hunger games sehen wollt erstmals
robben will was am problematischsten ist
mit mir aufnehmen welche mit gehen wir
noch einen moment ich nehme man mensch
mensch mensch so widmann immer gestört
hier in noch 14 sekunden noch okay also
was ihr haben wollt könnt ihr einfach in
die kommentare schreiben
sei es was gibt's nachricht aktiv
anderen deswegen ist das alles nicht so
komisch es geht los also salzhandel
gamestop und man will irgendwann einfach
schreiben
ich brauche jetzt erst mal ein paar alte
miss
darum ist schon schwer
recht das ist doch total kaka einfach
nur dass er so rumliegt
ein mensch wert ist kaputt ach ja die
alten zeiten nicht solange gott ich
sollte jetzt echt mal öfter spielen so
der ist weg der kommt nicht mehr hoch
ich muss erstmal hier irgendwie hoch
springen so hier bin ich das mal sicher
nein das war dass er sehr klug
warum nicht beschwert dass es ist sehr
gut sehr gut das schwert
hallo hallo hallo hier war der partner
der usa übrigens freunde in letzter zeit
kam ja sehr wenig videos beziehungsweise
hauptsächlich wie zivis das ist einfach
daran war ich gerade etwas sehr sehr
großes am planen bin mit einem freund
dieser stelle grüße an steffen nein also
ihr könnt euch auf was gefasst machen
dass wir ein buch von ihm dass er
hochsprang hinter mich und versucht mich
darüber zu kicken aber ich habe ihn
zerstört okay das ist ganz cool wie viel
ich im chat so hätte also wie viele ich
wirklich treffe das ist eine sehr gute
runde eigentlich waren bogen das
natürlich darauf den händchen und ich
nehmen müssen
wiederum lost destroyed okay gut ich
versuche jetzt von den war hier nicht
alle tempelmann nicht gewesen ich
darunter geflogen wäre also ich weiß ja
nicht ob gerade noch unsicher ist oder
ob das einfach nur wieder ein fehler ist
dass ich keine gegner sehe ich glaube ja
dass gerade dahin so ein spiel fehler
sonst wenn die restaurants liegt könnte
es einfach in die kommentare schreiben
and management
das und reaper monster eck
oh wie toll die spinne klasse und die
greift mich auch noch an
also ich weiß nicht wo die gegner sind
doch da war keiner da ist eine se mal
drauf weiß ja was geht
oder ist ein apfel jetzt kann obwohl
dass es ein date ist das oder sowas
mann ich will zurück nach lässt sich
werfen können damit bekommt 8 kg hier
innerhalb von kürzester zeit total
abgesagt das erschwert
er wusste ja nein nein jetzt verdammt
egal mal wieder eine runde smash also
wenn ihr das spiel wird für ein paar
kurze passagen wo ich einfach nicht
geredet habe das einfach weil ich muss
mich bei solchen sachen immer ein
bisschen konzentrieren übrigens auch
sehr cool dass wir meistens nur
engländer drauf sind weil der kennt
michael kleiner aber trotzdem wenn ihr
spielen wollt es in der beschreibung
und ja wenn es euch gefallen könnt ihr
einfach einen daumen hoch gehen und die
kamera in die kommentare schreiben
welche spielmodi ihr sehen wollt also
welche pvp sachen so für zwischendurch
außer feed the beast eilt ist ja
mittlerweile auch schon pvp zwischen
simon und ihren besuch für ihn station
soll ein echter kong kräfte augen kam
ich kenne doch welche da denke ich
manchmal ganz schnell runter und wir
sind eines neuen typs